author JD Vance wrote about the
disaffection felt by the country's
working class in the hillbilly elegy a
memoir of a family and culture in crisis
Nance is also a CNN contributor and he
joins us now from our Washington bureau
JD good morning good morning
no the anti-defamation league called
this the largest demonstration of white
supremacists in decades what do you
think's driving this well I think that
unfortunately we have a rise in identity
politics in the United States and a lot
of the folks who are most attracted to
this stuff are middle-class guys who
come from relatively well-to-do
circumstances and so it's difficult to
really say that there's a single thing
that's driving it I just think that what
we're seeing is a lot of disaffected
people who are turning to the very worst
ways to solve and address that
disaffection and it's something we've
got to deal with quite obviously but is
it driven by the economic insecurity
that you wrote about in your book yeah I
really don't think so and one of the
interesting things that I discovered
just when I was doing research for the
book and trying to understand the
different strains of resentment that
we're out there is that the alt-right
movement this neo-nazi movement is
actually really driven by well-to-do
middle-class folks people who have a
good education in some ways that's
perfectly highlighted by the organizer
of the rally yesterday who went to the
University of Virginia one of the
nation's great universities so it's it's
very tempting I think and comforting to
try to stereotype these white
nationalists as a bunch of
knuckle-dragging slack-jawed yokels but
the truth is that these are kids who are
doing pretty well and are still
attracted to this stuff and I think
that's a more troubling truth but it is
the truth I still don't understand why
they are attracting yeah III mean I I
struggle to understand it myself Charlie
the the the things that you notice that
that run pretty commonly through these
folks is that they're not doing
especially well in one facet of life or
another they have relationship problems
they don't do especially well with women
the thing that that jumped out at me
about mr. fields the attacker in
Charlottesville is that he appeared to
be a washout from the Army so these are
definitely people who have problems in
their lives but a lot of people have
problems in their lives and they don't
necessarily turn to white supremacism
and I think that that that means that
one
we should be aware of what's out there
but we should also not excuse and say
yeah this guy has a problem in his life
so that justifies some of the things
that he's turning to are they Trump
supporters and how much a percentage of
Trump supporters are they well yes some
of them are obviously Trump supporters
and you could see that in in the video
that went viral of David Duke chanting
that he was a trump supporter but I
really do think that this is a small
segment of those who support President
Trump and I think that's that's
something that's important to keep in
mind is that if we want to defeat things
like this we really have to find
something about our common shared
purpose as Americans and if we look at
the entire swath of Trump voters and say
you guys are neo-nazi supporters
then I think we're going to be
destroying some of the real cultural and
social capital we need to unite as a
country and actually defeat this stuff
shady from from your vantage point right
now what should the president be doing
well I think it is really important for
the president to name this particular
phenomenon if you think about all of the
controversy about whether Barack Obama
said radical Islamic terrorism there is
a real human need for people to have
their enemies named and described by
their political leaders and I think the
president really missed an opportunity
over the weekend hopefully an
opportunity he will take advantage of
today to name this enemy to describe it
and then to tell the country what we
need to do to defeat it you know it was
interesting to hear President Obama
tweeting on this issue because he is you
know he is kind of pulled back from the
debate but but quoting Nelson Mandela
that people are not born to hate that
that people must learn to hate and if
they can learn to hate they can also be
taught to love sure loved it go ahead go
ahead well yeah and if you look at some
of the responses to Charlottesville it's
always the silver lining and tragedies
like this is that people come together
they say the right things they support
and love one another and when I look at
what happened in response to
Charlottesville obviously the attack was
terrible but you actually see a
community coming together people of all
races and political affiliations coming
together to denounce this stuff and to
figure out what we're gonna do next some
people make the point that the President
Obama you know could not bring himself
to criticize fundamental radical Islamic
extreme
and and now we're asking President Trump
to do something again or groups that we
know are represent everything that
America doesn't yeah that's absolutely
right and it goes back to this point
that you know we we have a President of
the United States who isn't just a
political leader there also a moral
leader in some ways and people want to
know who is the enemy what are they
about
and what are we really fighting for and
I think that to have that conversation
you've got to name it that was true in
2016 2015 with President Obama and I
think it's true today with President
Trump thank you Judy yeah thank you guys
nice to have you thank you so much good
to talk to you